[Music]
women having trouble conceiving a child
have often reached out to fertility
clinics for help but now a new breed of
startup isn't waiting for the call these
boutique fertility operations are
encouraging clients in their 20s and 30s
to freeze their eggs to preserve the
prospect of a future pregnancy not
everyone is convinced this full profit
outreach is appropriate though many
clients are grateful they took up the
offer I've always known that I want kids
like I always like always tell everyone
I'm destined to be a mom
so when model Christa Mays found herself
single in her early 30s with the goal of
being a mom by age 35 she decided she'd
have to find a less traditional approach
than most to motherhood
I was having a conversation with my
girlfriend's about egg freezing and
fertility and the conversation I had was
like I think I'm gonna do this I don't
know anything about it I don't know what
office is to go to like how do I look up
on the computer fertility clinic that
wants somebody like me she came across
ads for kind body on Instagram the
fertility startup known for these bright
yellow vans offering blood tests to
measure the anti-mullerian hormone AMH
which is thought to be a marker of a
woman's remaining egg supply when I
found out that my MH was at 0.78 which
is low I basically just kind of said
okay what do I have to do
let's get your blood drawn okay Mays
went to have more testing done at kind
bodies New York City clinic that's when
she decided to freeze her eggs what was
it like he just laid down on the bed and
then your anesthesiologist just you know
get your IV going and then before you
know you wake up doctors were able to
retrieve seven eggs and with them the
hopes of a baby I'm feeling pretty good
just woke up from anesthesia you've
slowed your biological clock in a way or
you've taken your biological clock out
of the mix yeah yeah so I mean my eggs
are you know they'll be 3232 forever so
for me it was taking the opportunity to
ensure that I'll have children
regardless of my relationship situation
kind body is one of a growing crop of
companies suggesting young women protect
themselves against future infertility
you don't do anything about fertility
unless you're having a fertility problem
and we want to change that founding
physician dr. Fahy misison talks to a
packed room of young women at monthly
egg freezing 101 events and says ads
like this one which say freezing eggs is
like freezing time are not misleading if
your natural fertility is going to start
to decline or in your mid-thirties by
freezing your eggs you're giving
yourself the gift of time egg freezing
is not a guarantee to motherhood however
in a woman who is having difficulty
conceiving if she happens to have eggs
that are from her younger healthier
better quality version of herself it
will be easier for her to get pregnant
than if she who is having fertility
issues tries to use her own eggs at that
time according to the American Society
for Reproductive Medicine the rate of
women between the ages of 40 to 44
becoming first-time moms has been rising
since the early 80s the reasons include
careers a less than ideal relationship
status or finances to women in their 20s
will really need to be concerned with
their fertility so concerning means I'm
trying to scare you into something and
that's definitely not the process I want
you to be aware of it because I think
that knowledge is power that knowledge
bringing it to those 20 year olds allows
them to make a decision that's right for
them Gina Bart AZ is the founder and CEO
of kind body at about six thousand
dollars she says one egg freezing cycle
here not including medication costs far
less than at some major fertility
centers and could mean more savings if a
woman requires in vitro fertilization
later if you measure the cost of having
a
with your frozen eggs and you compare it
to multiple failed rounds of IVF every
single time the one cycle with those
frozen eggs yields a better outcome and
a more affordable solution but not
everyone is on board if there are issues
a reproductive endocrinologist should be
the person they should be providing all
this information to women and not
entrepreneurs dr. Pasquale Patricio is
the director at the Yale fertility
Center he worries about startups baiting
young women with flashy ads and AMH
testing for the great overwhelming
majority of women in their young age
there is no reason to offer single test
that by itself is completely inefficient
and only generates fear and panic but
dr. suzanne says kind body makes this
clear the initial tests in the yellow
van is not meant to be diagnostic AMH is
a piece of the puzzle some of the other
pieces are one just going over your
medical history and then a antral
follicle count which is a special type
of pelvic ultrasound or sonogram where
we can actually count the number of
follicles which are basically premature
eggs there isn't much data on the
long-term safety and effectiveness of
planned egg freezing especially when it
comes to eggs that were flash-frozen
using a relatively new technique called
vitrification the eggs are cooled an
ultra rapid rate to negative 196 degrees
Celsius 1 2017 studies suggested a 34
year old woman with 20 frozen eggs is
expected to have a 90% chance of having
at least one live birth a 42 year old is
expected to have a 37% chance
Crysta Mays says she's likely to go
through two more rounds of egg freezing
because she's hoping for more than one
child my goal that I've talked to you
about with my doctors is freezing twenty
eggs it is an investment but I felt like
it's it's a justified investment and an
important one to you yeah this is my
backup plan if I don't have a partner
and I can't do it the natural way in the
freeway my next option would be
to do this my biggest takeaway from
talking with all these women and some
other young woman is they want to know
their options and they're just not
hearing this from their doctors that
this is an option it's expensive but
what they're hoping at kind body is the
more that start to do this more
insurance companies will get on board
and that changes things super expensive
insurance policy but 25 years ago this
was not available to a lot of women and
you know availability opportunity always
a good thing it's a lot of sense